okay so I think I'm the token industry
guy here so I want to tell you about I
could go on about lots of things I've
learned from the car but I'm going to
restrict myself to five and i'm going to
try and explain each one of these
vignettes in two slides in one case i
think i go to three and along the way
highlight the contributions of some
colleagues are not here with us today
okay the first thing that everyone a
gnostic thinks about is the elegance of
everything he does almost everything he
does has some neat elegant observation
at its core okay and and i'm going to
begin with the simplest of possible
examples okay this is something
everybody in this room already knows
right which is randomized quicksort so
the way you start numbers is to pick a
random element from a set compare
everything in the set to it and break it
up to two sets which are called smaller
and larger recursively sort each
partition and then stitch it together
and a crucial observation here is that
once you do a split nothing in the
smallest set ever talks to anything in
the largest that ever again they are
parted forever okay and this continues
okay now if you go to the internet you
will find lots and lots and lots of
analysis of the number of comparisons
that quicksort takes many of them
running into pages and pages of
mathematics with sloppy constants in
quarters and three quarters here i'm
going to show you an analysis that i
learned over 30 years ago and i got
these from handwritten notes from the
carp in 1983 and in some office move
recently unfortunately I lost these
notes so if any of you has a copy I'd
love to get it back okay all right so
here's the central observation all right
so let's assume for simplicity and it's
not a big oversimplification that we are
sorting the integers 1 through n
okay and so let's look at the event that
I is compared to Jay okay that's all
we're going to focus on here right so a
couple of observations anything outside
the range I between I&J is immaterial to
this event ok so the event I gets
compared to Jay only depends on the
choice of splitters between I&J okay now
if anything between I&J is selected as a
splitter I and J shall never be compared
after that they are permanently parted
okay so the only way I is compared to
jay is if one of I and J is selected as
a splitter before anything in between
and off the I plus J minus 1 things in
contention there are only two choices
that cause I and J to be compared so the
event xij which is that I and J are
compared is true if and only if two of
these j minus i plus 1 things happen so
that has probability to over j minus i
plus 1 so the expectation of the
indicator variable x IJ is to over j
minus i plus 1 adding this overall IJ
but all I last Jen chieh all ordered
pairs gives you exactly the expected
number of comparison so notice that
thing near the bottom right is
inequality okay we don't have to mess
around with unknown constants see here
and then you want you can bound it from
above but to x and x natural log of M
it's about 1.38 and log in right that's
all
okay so dig in locks plagiarism in this
one I actually looked around the web
when the web is only finite to try and
trace down the origin of this proof and
after following a chain of steps i found
a comment from Abram Blum that
attributed to my book but I didn't get
it from I got it from these handwritten
notes yeah so i plagiarized from dick
right so so what's neat here is the Big
Island power of these indicator
variables and linearity of expectation
that's all there is to it and that's
something that you'll see a lot index
papers and some other papers by other
people whose work is similar job Spencer
no girl alone and so on right it's
surprisingly powerful okay so you don't
need anything more complicated in this
right there was two slides next one yet
power of randomization you could look at
Dick's work and probably come up with
over 50 examples that that tell us of
the amazing power of randomization and
I'm just going to pick one it's actually
work that by several people in this room
it turns out and I picked this because
the power of randomization in this case
is actually dramatic okay so let me
begin with the setting again one that
most of you are familiar with it's the
randomized cashing problem right so you
have this thing called a cash that can
hold k items at a time okay and then you
have a sequence of requests to items
that are in the cash and if the item
that's requested is in the cash you get
it for free otherwise you incur a Miss
okay when you have a mess the caching
algorithm must make a decision it must
evict something in the cash to make room
for the requested items okay and so an
online caching algorithm must make these
decisions online with no not knowledge
of the future and you want to compare
the rate at which it misses
to the miss rate of an offline algorithm
that is pressing that has infinite
knowledge of the future okay and so you
look at that ratio call it the
competitiveness of your online algorithm
right okay so this is what is known
before was that no deterministic
algorithm including LRU and other
commonly used algorithms can buy this
metric do better than a factor of K okay
so no deterministic online algorithms
competitiveness less than K and the way
you do this is you have a universe of k
plus 1 items so k of them will fit in
cache one of them has to sit outside and
the adversary having complete knowledge
of the state of any deterministic
algorithm can always shoot at the item
not in the cache okay and so any online
algorithm any deterministic all online
algorithm must incur a mess at every
single request whereas the offline
algorithm can always look out in the
future see which one will be farthest to
be evicted in the future and a big that
one okay so that lets it get by with a
factor of you know k advantage over the
online album okay now what I'm going to
do is describe the work in one slide
that dick and colleagues did to get a
randomized algorithm and it gets
dramatically but a competitive ratio and
I'll motivate the intuition of why okay
so this is work by a most feared pick up
my clue be live makea de nies later and
Neil Young ok and they call this marking
out let me quickly describe the
algorithm and then I'll tell you why it
gets such a big advantage ok so the map
marking algorithm gets a competitiveness
of two times the harmonic decay harmonic
number ok now crucial to this is is the
following modeling assumption that the
adversary specifies in advance the
request sequence of items to be sought
before the algorithm makes any random
choices ok so the only thing the
adversary is unaware office
random choices are actually made in an
execution of the algorithm okay all
right so so here's the algorithm it's in
addition to the kale cache locations
each location has associated with it a
bit a marking bit okay all of these bits
are initially 0 unmarked whenever there
is a hit on a cache location that bit
gets set to 1 so there's a mark that's
made there and when there's a mess in
order to determine which item in the
cache is evicted you look at all the
unmarked locations and evict one of them
at random okay and in this fashion when
all the bits in the cache get marked you
unmarked them all over again start all
over again and so the things sort of
proceeds and grounds of marking and
unmarked and I'm going to motivate the
intuition of why the adversary is is
folding in this book full to a
logarithmic factor rather than the way
it works again is there is let's think
of the case where there's only k plus 1
items so one of them is sitting outside
the cash and the adversary is trying to
shoot at that item to try and force a
mess okay the problem is because the
algorithms randomized the adversity
cannot predictably identify the item
that's outside so yeah adversary's
taking potshots at the request sequence
and so tries their no that's already in
cash market try that mark it try that
market and about halfway through these
random shots is lucky and gets to that
item that's outside the cash ok this is
intuition this is not a proof ok and
this carries on so each time you book
roughly you have the number of residual
unmarked items and by the time the round
is over the online algorithm has
incurred about logarithmic mimesis ok
and that's why you get this dramatic
advantage the fact that the adversaries
oblivious to what is outside the cash
all right dramatic improvement from a
factor of K to logarithmic and K my
third one yet has to do with something
dick always taught us too many times we
complicate analysis by early in the
analysis making choices that are
premature so so you would always say you
know defer your decisions in the
analysis okay I'm going to tell you now
about the homework assignment I actually
was a midterm that he gave us many years
ago it's again an extremely simple
setting that you'll all appreciate and
here it's more than the analysis the
algorithm itself entails deferral okay
so you want to set search in a set of
orderable elements okay think of them as
the integers okay so given the integers
and a query q and you want to determine
whether the queries and you're set its
standard search from okay all right so
if you do not sort the sect if you do
not pre sort it you got to make em
comparisons you basically have to
exhaustively compare your query with
everything in each element in the set
alternatively you could invest n log n
steps build a search tree and then each
query can be answered with login
comparisons right so what if the number
of queries that you're ever going to
answer is unknown it's some number are
okay and you don't know this in advance
it could be small in which case it
really makes sense to not sort it could
be large in which case to damage since
you sort right so those of you thought
about these things for a while are
thinking of ski rentals and so on okay
so when is it worth sorting can show an
information theoretical lower bound
straightforward argument that looks
something like this that covers both the
cases of our small and large okay so the
question that the open question I guess
we didn't realize was open when he gave
it in the midterm was can you do optimal
work for every are without prior
knowledge of our and the answer was a
piece of work I'm going to
quite sort of the the prefix of it and
then it went on to a number of other
cases another problems this joint work
with the regime attorney is to build a
search tree incrementally as queries
arrive okay so here's what you do when
the first query arrives you compare it
you do it if sorry you pick a random
element split it like you do in fix out
determine which subset the query might
fall into go in there and do this
recursively okay so when you're done if
life is fair you've done about you've
answered the first query with about 2 n
comparisons okay which is not too far
off the best you could do but at the end
of answering the first square you've got
a partially built search tree right
you've got this blob here you've got two
smaller blobs here but wait you've
expanded one of the smaller blobs in
smaller blob and smaller blob all the
way down to the leaf right so on each
subsequent query as more queries arrive
you develop this partially built search
tree and after enough queries arrive
you've got a fully built search tree
okay and if this happens then you can
show that with high probability this
matches the lower bottom okay you can
also do this deterministically in more
messily but this is sort of the simple
clean way to do it okay so by not doing
up front the work of building a search
tree you actually do about as well as
you can okay now Reggie motwani was a
horrible procrastinator and he summed up
this work with great satisfaction by
saying never do today what you can
postpone to tomorrow ok the next story
I'm going to tell you is one thing that
struck me as a graduate student was we
would have a large number of seminar
speakers would come in from all over the
world and give talks at Berkeley and as
I SAT there in the audience it struck me
how intimidating it must have been for
these speakers to have big carp in the
audience because the speaker would go on
and say you know define the alpha beta X
by matching problem and they could put
up a sign and say think that trivially
reduces to ports post correspondence
problem or something like that and you
know the speaker shattered right so he
had a way of seeing deep deep
connections between things that were
seemingly disconnected and so to this
end i'm going to show you one such
connection from problems and
connectivity okay now what I'm about to
show you may look a little / same but I
want you to think back to the world of
the 70s so so the problem is given an
undirected graph in two nodes S&T
determine if you are connected right and
so again today we know a great deal
about this problem but back then this
wasn't a variable in this trip problem
especially if you have small space so
savage had proven his theorem and the
question that the Roma Sally Lynn has
dick dick Lipton here Charlie Rakoff and
lassie Louis answered was can we decide
this in logarithmic space and they said
yes in randomized large space simply by
doing a random walk from s and after a
while you ought to end up a key well how
much time about n cube steps ok and this
may seem quaint now because we know so
much more about this problem but back
then this was the state-of-the-art ok
one thing this spawned was a cottage
industry in in this community on on
doing all sorts of neat things with
random walks and undirected graphs and I
confess to being guilty of a part of
that industry right and and there is one
result from there that I want to tell
you about today ok and this is strictly
with with having to do the random box
right so we were interested in the
hitting times of random walks and
undirected graphs and this happened one
summer in the group of a genre at at IBM
and
Larry busa and I were interested in how
do you characterize hitting times and
the particular beast we were looking at
was something called the commute times
so it's a time for a random walk to go
from s to key and back to us okay and
one of the interns there was Roman
smolenski and he did sort of a drive by
theorem he he walked by and he said what
are you guys working on said you know
we're starting the commute time and you
know it's the weirdest thing it could be
as little as and and it could be as much
as I'm cubed and what is it in graphs
that could possibly do that and he said
oh I bet it's the electrical resistance
and he walked away right and then the
rest of us spent you know a few weeks
deciphering is comment and deriving a
lot of consequences all right so the
thing I want you to note is there is a
red box there with an equality in it
okay it's not a bound it's not an
approximation is inequality okay what is
the Equality say it says the expected
length of a random walk from s to T and
back to s is two times the number of
edges times the electrical effective
resistance between S&T where every edge
in the graph is replaced by a 1 ohm
resistance now if you forgot me high
school physics this may take a little
bit of regurgitation okay but this is
you know the kind of blinding insight
that dick would show in these talks
Roman Smolinski showed here and the
proof is actually fairly straightforward
you just realize that the system of
linear equations characterizing hitting
times on an undirected graph is exactly
the same as kerkoff's laws governing the
flow of you know currents in a resistive
Network and that's all there is to it ok
let me come to my last oh and the one
thing I would point you to is if you've
never looked at it this this beautiful
monograph by Doyle and Snell that
connects random walks in electric
networks
it would take you two hours to read it
the first time but then I would urge you
to read it again and again it takes a
while to sink in at least it did for me
and it's it's absolutely gorgeous all
right now we all think of you know Dex
prowess with combinatorics and
probability and and the depth of his
work what many of us fail to recognize
is that his work has tremendous
practical utility and has continued to
do that and I've never figured out
whether dick seeks out utility in the
work he does or whether utility somehow
finds in and and so I'm going to give
you my final example from from the world
of computer systems ok so the particular
object here we worry about is something
called distributed hash tables and this
is an extremely important primitive in
large-scale distributed computing right
so so you have these files and they need
to be stored somewhere at server nodes
and the basic primitive you get is you
need to add files you could take away
files you go to access files efficiently
and all of this in an environment where
servers can appear and disappear
unexpectedly right I mean this may seem
obvious but many of us don't do the
numbers if a server is up 99.99 percent
of the time that looks great until you
have 10 million servers okay then a lot
of them are going down a lot of time
okay all right what do you want from
such a system it's got to be scalable
okay so when the number of users on the
internet doubles next year or the number
of documents and files doubles next year
you got to keep up with it you have to
have good performance so you want in in
a real environment to get hold of files
wherever they are in you know a couple
hundred milliseconds it's got to be
simple okay this system should be
something that doesn't take you know
2000 developers to keep alive and so the
solution that I'm going to describe to
you is work of Wrath asami Francis
handicapped and Schanker and these
according to the paper they were
inspired by an app store so these are
things called content addressable
network so so what was their idea right
what they said was let's envision a
d-dimensional towards ok so each node
gets mapped to a random point in this
torrid on the stories and by a sequence
of maintenance step to the detail owns a
rectilinear zone of the tourists around
its position ok if file is stored is
also similarly hashed to a point in the
D dimensional tourists and is stored at
the node whose own owns that earning
that node that's all ok right to get
through the network from a requesting
node to a node having a file you just
walk through these Manhattan zones and
the nice thing is each of these zones
each node has to only connect to a
constant number of neighbors so that's a
nice feature in the design sorry yeah
sorry i was thinking of d a small done
points are just bigger of d so where d
is the number of dimensions correct all
right as nodes are I've and I these
zones get split or koya list through
local updates so that's a very nice
property in terms of simplicity you
don't have to maintain any notion of a
global state all right and if you want
to get enough redundancy and durability
and robustness you insured this by
overlaying multiple thorac spaces ok and
so so you have several of these networks
overlaid and multiple hash functions ok
so that's great you're probably thinking
well I never thought of dick as a
Napster kind of person so
where do these ideas actually get used
right now my day job entails taking care
of a bunch of large services like Gmail
and Google tribes and without getting to
the exact numbers the number of files we
think about has at least four commas in
it and I don't know if that's probably
lost in the Europeans here but that's in
the trillion-plus range the number of
nodes is in the million-plus range right
so without getting into exactly how this
is implemented these ideas are extremely
influential and if you look at the
picture I'm about to show you really
really hard you'll find tix work in
there thank you dick for all you've done